[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland a product
manager at Google and your host at this
year's cop-con Copenhagen I'm joined by
one of my colleagues young Tottenham
Uche he's a software engineer at Google
and a real expert on G RPC
load-balancing yon
tell us a little bit about what makes G
RPC load-balancing essential to high
availability applications in kubernetes
okay so if I was to say it in a few
words
it's basically load balancing is one of
the key techniques that allows you to
build scalable applications and one of
the things that are maybe a little bit
less obvious that it also allows you to
make your your services more reliable
and to be able to do things like life
updates right and that's that's a core
piece of what happens in google
kubernetes engine right oh yes so for on
kubernetes that's basically like you
can't really not do load balancing when
you're deploying to - you know
kubernetes it's simply the right way to
deploy applications at scale yes okay I
understand you have a demo here for us
you want to show us how this works
okay so what I have here is so basically
a so I've already deployed a service
that has three replicas and I'm gonna
show you that these three replicas are
really here so you can see there's three
endpoints and now I'm gonna deploy a
client on the kubernetes cluster so I'm
gonna create it based on my llamo
definition I just created and when I
show you the locks you can see that the
client basically reaches to all of the
three existing replicas and it's doing
the round-robin load balancing using the
load balancer that's built into the ER
PC client itself so let's now see what
happens if let's say - my replicas die
it's gonna take a little bit but now you
can see that one of the last back-end
some of the last backends that we are
each - oh it's it's only the one last
remaining back-end and the other ones
you know are unfortunately dead so
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
and I could also easily scale up if I
wanted to yeah it might take a little
bit longer than scaling down because you
know when they die they're immediately
gone and it might take a little bit for
like the DNS resolution to pick up and
to see those things or like I don't know
if that's gonna work immediately so now
we should be reaching all of the five
near replicas actually examples that you
know are a little bit more complex than
this oh they are in a public github
repository that's like available to
everyone so I welcome everyone to go
ahead and try all those examples that's
great thanks John